Prof: So in Monday's
lecture we let something slip by
all of us without comment that
we probably should not have let
slip by,
and it's something I want to
focus on today.
That is when we spelled out
Mill's harm principle I said,
"Is everybody sure they
know what it means?"
Never mind whether you agree
with it or not,
but whether you're sure that
you understand what he is
saying,
and we all agreed that at least
it was clear.
In fact, though,
it's ambiguous,
and the highlighted phrase is
the ambiguity I want to focus
on.
At the end of that long
paragraph I read you when Mill
is saying,
"If you think something's
bad for somebody or that they
shouldn't do it,"
remember I gave you an example
of going to law school when I
don't think it's good for you.
Mill says, "Those may be
good reasons for remonstrating
with him,
or reasoning with him,
or persuading him,
or entreating him,
but not for compelling him or
visiting him with any evil in
case he decides to do otherwise.
To justify that (I need to
justify forcing somebody to do
something or prohibiting
somebody from doing something)
the conduct from which it is
desired to deter him must be
calculated to produce evil to
someone else."
"Must be calculated to
produce evil from someone
else."
And there are two issues raised
by that phrase that I really
want us to focus on with
laser-like intensity in today's
lecture.
The one is signaled by the
passive voice in it,
"must be calculated."
Well, that obviously puts on
the table, who does the
calculating, right?
And secondly,
what does it mean,
calculated?
It could mean calculated as in
intended.
"I didn't intend to harm
you.
There was no calculation to
harm you when I got
paralytically drunk behind the
wheel of a car,
and then I don't even remember
putting the keys in the wheel
and driving off.
I didn't intend to harm
you," right?
Or is it a third party
calculation?
Again, then we get to the
question, by whom?
Who's going to decide?
Who's going to do the
calculating?
So what does calculated
actually mean,
and who is it that's going to
do the calculating?
Those are the things we're
going to zero in on today.
And I thought the best way into
it was to consider some
examples.
And one I left you with on
Monday was, what about
prostitution?
This is what is sometimes
referred to as a so-called
victimless crime.
After all, the transaction
between a prostitute and a
client is a Pareto superior
transaction, right?
It's a voluntary market
transaction.
They wouldn't do it if it
didn't make both people better
off.
So should we just say from
Mill's point of view,
"There's no harm here;
it truly is a victimless crime
and we shouldn't make things
criminal if they are
victimless?"
How many people think that
makes sense?
About half.
Who thinks it doesn't make
sense?
Nobody?
Yeah. Okay, so why?
Why doesn't it make sense,
somebody who thinks it doesn't
make sense?
Over here?
Why were you thinking it didn't
make sense?
Student: Even though
it's victimless I think harming
yourself has some sort of
implications,
I think.
Prof: So it's the
prostitute harming herself?
Student:  Sort of.
I think there are some moral
implications in there that must
be dealt with.
Prof: Like what?
What kinds of implications?
Student:  Besides just
harming--okay,
let me take that back,
harming yourself.
It might harm society in the
sense that it brings down
society's moral standards,
I guess.
Prof: Okay,
it might harm society.
Mill's very clear that he wants
to reject the idea that there
are social rights,
so he wouldn't accept that,
but I don't think you should
give up so quickly.
Is there some other way of
articulating what you have in
mind there when you say harm
society?
What do you mean?
If you unpack what does it mean
when you say,
"harm society?"
It's tricky.
Anyone else want to have a go?
Yeah, right behind you.
Student:  I guess it
poses a negative externality on
society, and therefore...
Prof: Okay,
and what is the negative
externality?
Student: Well,
I guess in the case of
prostitution it could be the
objectification of women in this
case.
Prof: Objectification of
women, okay.
How would we say that's a harm
to society?
Maybe it would be--again,
Mill's going to reject the idea
that society has a right not to
be harmed.
How can it play out in a way
that doesn't involve making that
claim that society...?
Student:  Well,
I guess you could say it poses
a negative externality on the
individuals in the society by,
I guess...
Prof: On women.
Student:  Yeah.
It poses a negative externality
on women.
It reinforces the set of
stereotypes and so on.
Okay, so that might be one way
in which prostitution causes
harm.
Any other ways? Yes, sir?
Student:  It could also
be said that it has a negative
externality because it
undermines family values.
Prof: It undermines
family values.
Student:  Which would
then, in turn,
hurt children and the future
generations.
Prof: And that would,
in turn, hurt children.
Yeah?
Student:  Well,
I think it's difficult also to
disconnect prostitution from
this sort of theoretical model
from the actual model of
prostitution.
I think when we put pimps,
and sexual slavery,
and that sort of thing in the
picture then the harm becomes
far more real,
and it's questionable whether
people are voluntarily
participating in these
transactions to begin with.
Prof: Okay,
so if you're a really
hardboiled Millian libertarian I
think slavery's not an issue.
Slaves are taken by force,
but selling yourself into
indentured servitude is not
obviously something--
would Mill say you should be
allowed to do that?
It's your choice.
It's tricky because you're
really giving up your autonomy.
You'll see in politics,
we confront later in the
course,
what do you do with an election
where a party runs,
as in Algeria in 1991 saying,
"If elected we are going
to abolish democracy,"
and they get elected.
In that case the Algerian
military stepped in.
If somebody says,
"I'm going to sell myself
into servitude,"
it's a voluntary act,
should we save them from
themselves?
That's a very tricky one,
but let's set those ones aside.
And I think there would be
similar issues with suicide for
Mill.
Should you be allowed to stop
people committing suicide?
Those are very hard.
I think they're separate,
though, from these issues about
what we're calling
externalities.
People are saying,
"Of course there are
harmful effects of prostitution.
It harms women.
It undermines certain kinds of
moral codes.
What would Mill say in response
to that?
Yeah?
Student:  Well,
I think for Mill it really
depends on the context of an
act.
So you can be drunk at home,
but you can't be a policeman
drunk on the job.
So if we look at prostitution
if you're working as a free
agent,
sure, you can engage in
prostitution,
but if you're a father and
you're married then he should
probably view that as something
not okay.
So it really matters for him
what the context is of a certain
transaction.
Prof: Okay,
I think that's right,
and you could imagine a more
refined version of the harm
principle that tried to
incorporate that.
I gave the example last time;
I think I said,
"Mill would presumably be
completely comfortable without
outlawing drunk driving and
punishing that activity,
but not punishing
drinking."
So presumably the principle
would be some version of
"interfere with human
conduct as little as possible to
prevent harm,"
right?
So it's killing a gnat with a
sledgehammer to outlaw drinking
just because some people drive
drunk.
I think that's fair enough.
But I think some of the people
who were saying allowing
prostitution has bigger negative
externalities wouldn't give up
that quickly.
Anyone who thinks we shouldn't
give up that quickly,
that there's something else
here?
Nobody?
Maybe they would give up that
quickly.
Okay, we'll leave that aside
for a minute and come back to
it.
So if you're now bearing this
in mind go back and reread On
Liberty.
I think what you'll come away
with is it's actually quite
confusing just what Mill means
by harm.
Because some harms,
he wants to say,
are trivial harms,
so the harm you suffer through
not getting a place in college
in a competitive exam,
right?
He's not going to allow that
harm ultimately to be
dispositive.
He's going to allow that to be
outweighed by the benefits to
society of competitive
meritocracy.
And remember our free trade
discussion last time.
So some harms are more
significant than other harms and
some harms are outweighed by
utilitarian benefits.
It seems like,
some of the time,
if Mill's saying,
"Prohibition shouldn't be
allowed,"
he's saying essentially,
"Unless I intend to do you
some harm.
You might find it offensive
that I sit around drinking all
day, but it's none of your
business.
You might have family values
which say that if there are
people out there who are
prostitutes, it undermines the
family.
That's your family value,
thank you very much.
It's not my family value,"
right?
So you could take that view.
And after all,
if you think about the debate
we've had in this country about
gay marriage over the past
decade or so,
that's exactly the claim and
the counterclaim,
right?
Some people say,
"There's no reason in the
world that gay people should be
prevented from getting married.
They're not hurting anybody
else."
And then people say,
"Well, that undermines
traditional family values,"
right?
And the people who support gay
marriage say,
"Well, so what?
Those are your traditional
family values,
but they're not our traditional
and why should yours...."
This is, after all,
what Mill says,
the tyranny of majority
opinion.
So what? Right?
This is supposed to protect
individual freedom against it,
so one person's traditional
family values is another
person's tyranny of majority
opinion.
How are you going to resolve
that?
What mechanisms does Mill have
to resolve that?
And I think you could read
On Liberty
with a fine-tooth comb
and not come up with one,
and so you could say,
"Well, so much the worse
for Mill.
We thought we had this
wonderful rights-utility
synthesis where all good things
would go together.
We could respect individual
freedoms,
and promote social utilitarian
efficiency based on science all
at the same time,
but actually it turns out to
all be resting on a hill of
sand,
and the minute you walk on it
you start sinking."
And I think this is a good time
to go back to the point I made
to you right at the beginning of
the course when I said you
shouldn't be expecting the
silver bullet in this course.
You shouldn't be expecting to
find the theory that answers all
your questions.
What instead you're going to
find is particular insights that
you can pick up and put into
your bag of tricks and move on
with.
Because I think it is,
at the end of the day,
a good critique of Mill to say,
"There is no single
definition of harm and there's
no good account of who makes the
decisions about harm."
And so to that extent his claim
at the beginning of On
Liberty that there's one
simple principle and this is
what it is, fails.
Nonetheless,
there are some important and
enduring insights here that I
think we're not going to want to
let go of.
One is, when you think about
all of the ways human beings
interact,
and all of the things we do
that cause us to have the
possibility of bumping into one
another,
maybe it shouldn't be the case
that there is a single
definition of harm because
different definitions of harm
are relevant to different types
of situation.
This is a little like the point
somebody here made that Mill
would be interested in the
context.
If you think about physicians;
we allow physicians to buy
malpractice insurance in case
they kill you by mistake when
they're doing surgery,
but we don't allow bank robbers
to buy malpractice insurance so
that if they kill you by mistake
when they're robbing a bank they
can get off.
That tells you right there,
there must be different
conceptions of harm that operate
in different circumstances.
And indeed, if you want to
start thinking about it a little
bit more systematically,
harm is treated very
differently in different
situations.
Think about this continuum I've
put up here.
Some kinds of harm are
completely excluded.
You're not held responsible for
them at all.
If you have a death penalty and
legal execution of people,
of course you harm the person
you execute.
Certain kinds of wartime
killing, of course you harm the
person that you kill,
but we allow it.
We don't count it as a relevant
harm.
Then here, I'm going down this
continuum, we say that the
intention to kill is very
important in the criminal law.
Does anyone know what this term
mens rea is in the
criminal law?
No reason you should,
but somebody might.
If you're charging somebody
with a criminal offense the
government has to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt various
elements of the crime,
that the person did it,
that in fact that the crime
occurred and that there was
something called mens
rea,
or criminal intent.
"Guilty mind,"
that's what it means.
And in the criminal law we make
that one of the elements of the
crime.
That's why things like the
insanity defense become so
contentious because the person
claims,
"Well, because I didn't
know what I was doing,
I didn't have mens rea.
My client didn't have mens
rea.
He didn't know what he was
doing so he's not guilty by
reason of insanity.
He's not guilty," okay?
Or if you think about--you
might say,
"Well, we do imprison
people for vehicular homicide
when they get drunk,"
and the person says,
"But I didn't intend to
kill them.
I didn't know I was driving.
How can you can you say I
intended?"
Interestingly there we come up
with a doctrine in the legal
system which we call
constructive intent.
And what is the doctrine of
constructive intent?
It's basically we say,
"Well,
any reasonable person would
know that if drive down to a
bar,
and you have no way to get
home, and you then drink ten
beers you would be putting
yourself in the position where
could harm someone.
So we're going to impute the
intent to you even though you
didn't have it."
That's the doctrine of
constructive intent.
That's using exactly that kind
of situation,
so in the criminal law,
to go back to Mill,
we'd say "calculated to
produce evil in someone
else."
It's got to be calculated by
the person committing the harm,
okay?
So, why is that, you might say.
Well, criminal actions are
actions which bring moral
opprobrium on people.
We lock them up.
They're really things we don't
want people to do,
and we want people to
internalize the incentive not to
do them.
So it's about their intentional
actions, and then we're
punishing them for those
actions.
Therefore, when we put
sanctions on them we want them
to know that they could have
behaved otherwise,
and so we want the intent to be
present,
so constructive intent is sort
of like intent,
but not exactly.
What about negligence?
Negligence is even less like
constructive intent.
So negligence is the doctrine
that let's suppose you live in a
neighborhood where there are
lots of children,
small children,
and you put in a swimming pool.
And let's say the law requires
that you fence in your swimming
pool,
but you leave the fence open,
the gate open,
and a child goes in and falls
into your pool and drowns.
The doctrine of negligence
would say,
"Well, yes of course you
didn't intend that the child
would drown,
but you were negligent in
leaving the gate open,
so we're going to hold you
responsible."
So it's a little less than
constructive intent.
It's negligent.
Any reasonable person would
know that you shouldn't leave
the gate open.
So you were negligent.
It's still a state of mind,
but it's obviously not the same
thing as intending to kill the
child.
And then we could go even
further down the continuum and
say,
"There are some situations
where we say,
'We don't care about your state
of mind at all.'"
So if an adult has sex with a
14-year-old and walks in and
says,
"Well, Your Honor,
she said she was 20,
and I thought she was 20.
She looked 20,"
and perhaps that's true.
Perhaps all of those things
were true, she said she was 20,
I thought she was 20 and she
looked 20.
"We don't care,"
we say as a society.
We don't care.
That's the notion of statutory
rape.
It's sometimes called strict
liability.
We're going to hold you liable
anyway.
And why do we do that?
Presumably to give people the
incentive to make sure as to
find out.
So when we say,
"If she was 14 it's
statutory rape,
or if he was 14 and she was 20
it's statutory rape,"
there it is,
too bad.
We don't care what she said,
and we don't care what you
believed at the time because we
want to ensure that people have
the incentive to find it out
correctly."
Or we could think of Good
Samaritan laws.
This is the situation where
you're walking along,
and you see somebody drowning
in a lake,
and at very little cost to
yourself,
you could pull them out,
but you say,
"I'm late for class,
never mind.
I didn't push her in the
lake."
In many states we have good
Samaritan laws,
which if it really was at no
trivial cost to yourself you
could have done that,
you can be prosecuted for
failing to assist somebody in
need of your help,
okay?
So that's obviously a very
capacious definition of harm.
I mean, after all,
the fact that we're all sitting
here rather than doing relief
work in Haiti right now means
presumably that some people are
suffering,
perhaps even dying as a result
of our failure to go to Haiti
right now.
So once you go over this line
into treating omissions to help
as a form of harm,
as we do with Good Samaritan
laws, where will it end,
right?
So you can see from this that
if you wanted one definition of
harm to cover all situations
that obviously isn't going to
make any sense.
Nonetheless,
if you think about this
continuum, where you fall on it
has huge implications for how
you're going to run your
society.
And more interestingly than
that, I've given you a kind of
static picture now,
but these things actually
change.
Think about the drug
thalidomide.
Who knows what happened with
thalidomide?
Yeah, what happened with
Student:  It came out in
the late '50s.
It was used to treat morning
sickness and it turns out that
the racemate of the drug causes
teratoma in children born to
women taking the drug.
And so it was basically a
failure of the drug industry to
look into the effects of the
different structures of drugs in
humans.
Prof: Correct.
That's a very good summary.
And what's interesting about
thalidomide from our point of
view is that in developing this
drug,
which was given for morning
sickness,
the pharmaceutical companies
didn't cut any corners.
They did all the clinical
trails correctly.
They got the FDA approvals.
Everything was done by the book.
Nothing illicit was done,
and at that time the general
standard in tort liability--who
knows what tort means,
t-o-r-t?
Not t-o-r-t-e,
we're not talking about
chocolate cake.
What's a tort?
Nobody knows what a tort is?
Tort just means harm, right?
So the general standard for
tort liability was negligence,
and they weren't negligent.
They did it by the book.
They got all of the approvals.
They got the clinical trials.
The FDA approved the drug.
And it's a famous case because
it was an instrument by which
the courts decided to say,
"You know what?
We don't care.
We don't care."
They moved from negligence to
strict liability.
"We don't care that you
did it all right.
The fact is,
there are all of these children
who were born with missing
limbs, and you're going to pay.
You, the drug companies,
are going to pay.
We're going to hold you
strictly liable.
We're going to treat it like
(the example I gave before)
statutory rape."
Now, you might say,
"Well, why?
Why would you do that?"
And interestingly the move in
American tort law from
negligence to strict liability,
those of you who go on from
here to the Yale Law School will
learn all about it because the
intellectual giant of the move
from negligence to strict
liability was Guido Calabresi,
long time Dean of the Yale Law
School,
and now a Federal Judge on the
Second Circuit.
He wrote a book called The
Costs of Accidents.
And the main argument of The
Costs of Accidents was--this
was actually about auto
accidents.
It was essentially utilitarian
in that Calabresi looked at what
had already stated in New Jersey
at that time.
If people rear-end one another
in cars you can say,
"Well, who was negligent
here?"
Was it the driver in front,
or was it the driver in the
back?
If it was the driver in the
front,
why, "Oh,
well, he stopped too
quickly,"
or something like that,
or the driver at the back says,
"Well,
my brakes weren't working or
the driver at the front's brake
lights weren't working."
You have an argument.
And they have their lawyer,
and you have your lawyer,
and you duke it out,
and somebody wins and somebody
loses.
New Jersey said,
"It's not worth it.
It's a waste of court time.
It's a waste of everybody's
time.
So we're going to make the law
which says, in a rear-ending
situation, the driver at the
back pays, always."
Kind of rough justice,
sometimes maybe the brake
lights on the front car really
weren't working.
"We don't care.
It's just not worth the State
of New Jersey's time to invest
the institutional resources and
all the rest of it to allow
people to litigate these things.
It just costs too much.
It's not worth it."
So Guido Calabresi came up with
a little algorithm in which he
said,
"The standard should be to
minimize the cost of accidents
plus the cost of their
avoidance."
So you figure out the cost of
all the rear-ending,
right?
And then you figure out,
well, if we allow people to sue
what's the cost of avoiding
accidents that way,
whereas if we don't allow them
to sue for negligence,
what's the cost that way?
It's cheaper.
It's more efficient.
And anyway, there are probably
some good side benefits;
it gives the person at the back
the right incentive to keep a
distance they can stop,
right?
So we make a utilitarian
judgment.
The game's not worth the candle
for negligence.
That's one defense of it.
Coming back to the thalidomide,
minimize the cost of accidents
and the cost of their avoidance.
What do we want as a society?
We want the drug companies to
have the incentive to go the
extra mile to do even more
research than they have to do as
required by the FDA,
to buy the insurance because
perhaps they're the deepest
pocket.
They have the resources to do
the research and to buy the
insurance.
If you're a pregnant woman
thinking about taking a morning
sickness pill or not taking it,
you don't have the resources to
do extra research.
So we put the burden on the
party who can most cheaply avoid
it.
Now, the drug companies are
saying, "That's outrageous.
It's totally outrageous.
We didn't do anything wrong and
you're punishing us."
Strict liability.
So we moved,
and the example of thalidomide
is just the tip of an iceberg.
In the whole of tort law
there's been this thirty or
forty-year move from a
negligence standard to a strict
liability standard.
And a fascinating intellectual
debate between Calabresi,
who's the champion of strict
liability,
and Richard Posner,
who you probably have read some
of his books,
a Judge in the Chicago Circuit
who defends negligence as more
efficient.
So it's a debate between
utilitarians in that sense.
And if we had more time I'd
have you read some of that
debate.
You might be convinced at the
end of it that Posner wins
intellectually,
but as a matter of the politics
of it, Calabresi wins.
That is to say American tort
law has moved,
since the 1950s,
away from negligence to strict
liability.
Let's think of another example.
In the 1950s in America,
a husband could not be
prosecuted for raping his wife.
There was no such crime.
There was, in other words,
a conclusive common law
presumption that there was no
such crime.
Now you might say, why?
Well, there's a historical
answer.
It went back to the suspension
of the legal identity of the
woman during marriage.
Essentially,
it goes back to the old
patriarchal laws.
The daughter was more or less
the father's property and then
he gave his property to the
son-in-law as the husband's
property.
So the woman didn't have a
legal identity as a person
during marriage,
and this is why she lost
control of her property,
right?
And that was restored,
ultimately, by the Married
Women's Property Acts that
recreated women's property
rights over,
say, inherited wealth or
whatever it was.
It didn't automatically become
her husband's property.
But there was this hangover
from the nineteenth century that
a woman couldn't be raped by her
husband,
and not only rape but other
things like assault.
So in other words,
you could walk up to a woman
you were not married to on the
street,
and punch her in the face,
and get arrested for that,
and convicted of assault,
but if you did it to your wife
there was no crime.
So then we have the women's
movement.
We have a lot of feminist
pressure and organization,
and so we now have gone to a
world in which marital rape is a
felony in about forty-five of
the states and the federal
system.
So it's gone from having a
conclusive common law
presumption against it,
to making it a felony,
and all the other things have
gone as well,
so inter-spousal tort immunity
is gone.
You can be prosecuted for
assaulting--in other words,
marriage is no longer a bar to
things that would be criminal
actions outside.
So we've had a huge change in
the law there from one
definition of what counts as a
relevant harm to a different
relevant harm.
In the first case it was an
argument about efficiency,
and the second is a political
movement.
The women's movement had this
enormous impact on the
redefinition of what sorts of
harms the state should take
seriously in marriage.
Let me give you a third example.
If you go into employment law,
or housing law,
or education,
the American courts have,
for many decades,
at least since Brown versus
Board of Education was handed
down by a unanimous Supreme
Court in 1954,
they've been concerned with
trying to get rid of
discrimination.
Discrimination's a kind of
harm, right?
So the question is;
what do you have to show?
What do you have to show to
convince the court that you've
been harmed and there should be
remedy?
What do you have to show?
And during the Warren Court it
was somewhat like strict
liability.
The Warren Court,
Earl Warren was appointed by
President Eisenhower in 1953.
Eisenhower thought he was
appointing a conservative
Justice, but he turned out to be
wrong.
Earl Warren was,
perhaps, the most liberal Chief
Justice of the twentieth
century.
And the court,
under his leadership,
developed the idea that all you
had to do was show there was a
pattern of discriminatory
effects.
You didn't have to show that
anybody intended to discriminate
against anyone.
So in the education area,
separate but equal,
the court said is inherently
unequal.
We're not saying that the White
southerners are necessarily
prejudiced against Blacks,
many of them were,
but we're not going to get to
that question.
We're just saying separate but
equal is inherently impossible.
It's an oxymoron.
You can't have it,
and we're saying that without
reference to the intentions of
school administrators or anybody
else.
In housing patterns you do
these kinds of studies like Ian
Ayres and the Yale Law School
here is well known for having
done.
When people with exactly the
same objective characteristics,
same income,
same employment history and so
on going for a mortgage it turns
out that African Americans are
denied mortgages at a higher
rate than non-African Americans.
You don't have to show that
that mortgage officer was a
racist, or was intending.
You produce the statistics,
you show people with these
objective characteristics who
are African American get denied
and those with the same
characteristics who are not
African Americans don't get
denied.
It's a patter of discriminatory
effects.
We don't have to get into
something like mens rea
or whatever is going on in the
bank mortgage officer's head.
So that was the standard also
in employment discrimination and
many other areas of the law of
discrimination under the Warren
Court.
All you had to show was a
pattern of discriminatory
effects.
But the Warren Court was
gradually replaced first by the
Burger Court,
then the Rehnquist Court,
and now the Roberts Court,
and in that conservative
evolution discrimination law has
gone this way on the continuum.
Now you can't get a remedy
unless you can show the
intention to discriminate on the
part of some public official.
So let's say in zoning
ordinances,
you've got to show that some
public official actually tried
to do the zoning in such a way
as to exclude Blacks from a
certain neighborhood,
let's say, before you can get a
remedy.
So in employment,
and housing,
and education,
and all of these areas of
discrimination we've gone the
other way as a society,
right?
We've gone from a very
capacious standard which would
allow a remedy just from the
objective indicators,
the patterns of discriminatory
effects,
now we treat it more like the
criminal law.
We say, "Unless you can
show,
you can establish in court that
there was some particular person
in that bank denying mortgages
who intended to discriminate,
no remedy."
So it's much harder,
of course, to get remedies.
So those are three examples.
Those are three examples,
the thalidomide,
the marital rape,
and the discrimination,
where you can see that there's
enormous flux in our society as
to what counts as a relevant
harm.
And if we had time,
I strongly suspect if we had
time to have a debate in this
room on those three topics it's
not like we would all agree as
to whether in discrimination law
it should be patented as
discriminatory effects or
intent.
We'd have differences of
opinion about that that would
stem from our assumptions about
the appropriate role of
government,
how intrusive it should be and
so on.
Or probably there would be less
disagreement today about the
martial rape than there would
have been in the 1950s,
and I suspect intuitions would
go all over the place about tort
liability and the thalidomide.
So what does that tell us?
And this is the second reason I
think it's really instructive to
work through somebody like Mill
even if, in the end,
Mill doesn't have the answer.
I think one of the lessons of
this course, and you can see it
here very dramatically,
is that it is impossible to get
rid of political disagreement.
It is impossible to reduce
political choices to scientific
choices all the way down.
Science can play important
roles in making political
choices,
but it can't make them for us,
so that one of the big goals of
the Enlightenment to come up
with scientific principles of
politics is never going to be
perfectly realized.
That doesn't mean it can't be
partially realized,
but it's never going to be
perfectly realized.
You can't wring the politics
out of politics.
There's no way to do it.
And so you will see when we
come to read Marx and he talks
about his utopian communist
society,
one of his one-liners is that,
at the end of the day when we
finally have the true communist
utopia,
"Politics will be replaced
by administration,"
right?
That's a bumper sticker for
saying we're going to wring the
politics out of politics.
Bentham, looking for the right
objective utilitarian calculus,
right?
Mill wants to say,
"Well, once the harm's
triggered we can do the
cost-benefit analysis on
scientific principles."
We talked about that last time.
Never works.
It never works all the way down.
It doesn't mean to say that
scientific thinking can't
condition our normative choices,
but you go back and think
through these three examples
that I've just given you these
are basically normative choices,
right?
In the 1950s when this issue
about marital rape came up,
a lot of things were said that
are similar to what is said now
about gay marriage.
People said if the state starts
prosecuting husbands we're going
to destroy the traditional
family.
And people the women's movement
said, "Great!
We're going to destroy this
traditional family because men
shouldn't be allowed to rape
women.
At least in this respect we won
it," right?
So traditional values only
takes you so far because the
harm principle is by definition,
a critical principle for
looking at traditional values
and saying,
"How much should we cater
to them,
how much not," right?
So these are political choices.
The choice about thalidomide
has huge distributive
consequences,
huge, enormous.
You're going to say to
pharmaceutical companies,
"You're going to be liable
from now on for the harmful
effects of your drugs regardless
of whether you got the FDA
approval."
It's a huge burden to put on
them.
Notice what we could say.
We could say,
"No, (as a famous
libertarian Judge Learned Hand
said) in society losses must lie
where they fall."
What does that mean?
It basically means the women
who had the thalidomide children
and the children themselves must
internalize the loss,
or we could say,
"We'll socialize the
risk."
We'll say, "In these kinds
of situations when there was no
wrongdoing in the sense of
cutting corners;
the government will bail them
out."
Just like we did after 9/11,
we created this huge fund and
paid compensation to the
relatives of people who died in
9/11.
Many people die all the time in
disasters where we don't do
that, but we could.
We could have massive social
insurance for unexpected harms.
So the choice to say,
"Losses must lie where
they fall,"
with Learned Hand,
or that we should socialize it
by saying,
"Well, if you're born with
a physical deformity,
obviously it's through no fault
of your own,
but really you can't blame the
manufacturer of thalidomide
either,
so the state will pick it up.
We as a society will do
it."
That's a different choice.
Or if you say,
"No, we're going to make
thalidomide--the manufacturer
internalizes this,"
that's a different choice.
My point here is it's always a
choice.
It's always a choice.
We'll come to read a
libertarian called Robert Nozick
later in the course,
and one of his one-liners is
that, "The fundamental
question of political theory is
whether or not there should be a
state."
But we'll see that that's a bit
like saying,
"The fundamental question
of dental theory is whether or
not there should be teeth,"
because in fact everything
involves collective choices.
Even the collective choice to
let the loss lie where it falls,
that is itself a collective
choice.
So you can't wring the politics
out of politics.
And at least one goal of the
Enlightenment,
we're going to see,
there's this idea of replacing
politics with science,
or in Marx's formulation,
of politics being displaced by
administration,
can never be perfectly realized.
And that's an important insight
we get from thinking about
trying to apply Mill's harm
principle.
Okay, see you on Monday.